hey what's up guys thanks for tuning in
to are you garbage please make sure you
go
subscribe to the youtube channel that
way you get the videos as they come out
yeah do it welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley ho ho ho
everybody and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast
this is are you garbage the show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and
find out if they grew up classy
or if they're in absolute trash i'm your
host states foley coming at you on a
beautiful day
down here in tutti's basement she's got
the joint set up nice for the christmas
now he needs a couple of bucks for
presents
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table
so you know what that means it's the
[ __ ] are you garbage christmas
special
extravaganza extravagant you are just
just for family yeah family episode
fan question episode we got a couple of
[ __ ] heaters coming in too we reached
out to the facebook group
and the [ __ ] patreon members and
everybody's coming through with some
[ __ ] hat
we want to wish you guys a happy merry
christmas to everybody
uh we love it my co-host put this all
together
all right put the cookies out for santa
i'm going to be turning in the receipts
at the end of the month too by the way
this is going right he's been footing
the bill on a lot of [ __ ]
fly-by-night expenses this is going to
go right back to cvs after this episode
turns out i'm jewish oh
i did get it at cvs can't be kevin james
ryan everybody hey gang what's up
everybody
as always thanks for tuning in we
appreciate all the support it's [ __ ]
fantastic it means
it means so much this has been a [ __ ]
whirlwind of a year for us i gotta say
we started off this year a couple of
[ __ ] slugs
and now we got a hot pot on our hands
daddy got our own office
got office space new york city and it
all it's
i can't stress it enough it's all the
[ __ ] fans it's all the [ __ ]
listeners you guys are the [ __ ] [ __ ]
the patreon members
everybody that allows us to [ __ ] do
this i thank you so much from the bottom
of my [ __ ] hat
that being said a little bit of business
to [ __ ] get into
daddy oh [ __ ] the kitties need their
breath let's go into the first quarter
hot gang
um guys please make sure you view
subscribe on itunes yeah
those we're almost at a thousand [ __ ]
itunes reviews hanging out there with
the big dog so get on it leave a [ __ ]
review and that's something you could do
for free that's a freebie
i don't care if you want to join the
patreon great if you want to buy a
t-shirt that's great
and if you're breaking covet laws this
year and you got a whole bunch of family
members on a holiday
go through some purses grab some phones
go to their itunes
why not ain't nothing wrong with it
you're home for the holidays grab mom's
[ __ ] cell phones you don't know
what's going on yeah
subscribe play a bunch of apps zoot it
up on coca-cola maybe venmo me a couple
of bucks
whatever you need uh guys uh actual also
full video available on youtube please
subscribe there we're almost at 10 000
subscribers we're flirting with it
coming up on 9
000 hd video hd video quality shot by
the [ __ ] man t-bone himself it's all
very good we appreciate that
and also patreon.com helps us pay the
bills helps us keep the [ __ ] lights
on let's us do this podcast as we want
to do it
no big corporate sponsors here daddy-o
that's right couple of kids running and
gunning with a patreon account that's
right
it's patreon.com ru garbage you can get
bonus episodes uh bonus episodes of are
you garbage bonus episodes of hard
feelings where it's me and foley behind
the curtains a little bit
yeah doing some mudslinging t-bone gets
in the mix
also too at the end of every month we're
doing i feel like you're reminding me of
this
i am yeah i can see your notes we got a
patreon
um also to i hate doing all this but we
got to do it you got to do it um
we do live streams with the top tier
people which we did last week which is
[ __ ] phenomenal
we're having a good [ __ ] time on
patreon get involved that's what you
need to know
tubby time with kippy went live today
episode number one
you gotta you get a shot at the old
sausage you know what i mean
that's it everybody thanks for tuning in
we appreciate it and check out
podcastmerch.com pick up a little
something for
somebody you love for the holidays and
might not get there before christmas
but who cares yeah and on that note
how about a nice big round of applause
for our producer extraordinaire
the [ __ ] magic man kid from chicago
small town kid went out there [ __ ]
wrigley field made it good
mm-hmm toby mcmullen everybody yeah hey
merry christmas pal i'm excited for my
christmas bonus i got the in-ground pool
going in
[Laughter]
put it over there grease paul hey
mcmullen have a good holiday
just watch chris's vacation still holds
the [ __ ] up
what does he get jelly of the month club
jelly of the month yeah
i'll tell you what if the kovids
has done anything it's you know for me
it's made me
take a minute appreciate things smell
the flowers a little bit
and uh you know even though we couldn't
you know go out see the tree do all this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
they're in a lot of money or you know
for for christmas presents this year
sure you know
i got the old macaroni and [ __ ] uh
elmer's glue out
fishing line and that [ __ ] [ __ ]
rigatoni
when you make something it's from the
heart yeah um but we you know we
decorated the apartment making a
snowball with
a snowman with cotton balls
i mean it's all [ __ ] up looking i used
to hate those days
those days in school where they're so
high pressure dude this sounds like
you got 25 minutes to make something for
your mom to make her [ __ ] proud or
you're gonna look like a loser
i'm doing the hand turkey freaking out
making an ashtray for her
i did make her enough yeah dude i made
my my mom didn't even smoke she was
getting [ __ ] ashtray what are they
doing wasting people's
kids times in [ __ ] elementary school
what else are they going to be
doing teach them how to [ __ ] balance
a checkbook some [ __ ] elementary school
whatever i could have used some [ __ ]
real world experience
i mean like right in the comments second
school district i could have used
something
not making a [ __ ] ashtray for my
[ __ ] mind to kill him
ooh you beat it shut the [ __ ] up i don't
know i appreciate it it was nice
you let the hair down a little bit you
know we could be learning a lot of
better things to prepare people for the
for
the next millennium h foley 2024
everybody jesus i didn't realize we're
gonna get so [ __ ] political in the in
the
christmas episode i didn't like making
that [ __ ] okay well it was [ __ ] 50
years ago let it go
you got bigger fish to fry that's
patreon.com
i got a cup of coffee right jesus christ
what were we talking about
supposed to be christmas you were saying
you were saying you were decorating on
your own
oh yeah we were really getting into it
you did a tree i didn't get a tree yet
we're gonna get a treat we did a little
baby cheer we usually do a big size tree
but we're not gonna be here for actual
christmas so we got a little baby one
yeah and then we've been watching the
movies we've been [ __ ] making coco
i made a gingerbread house who would
have known he did that in august too
though so
it's not that special real tree or fake
tree growing up
oh who's this bozo where's this guy just
checking in what are you talking about
that's 60 episodes in we got taylor we
paid our rent for real
trees yeah we did have a fake one for a
few years i think my brother was like
really allergic
we got a fake one now you guys saw it
when you went down to film the thing
yeah yeah that's different your parents
are old and out to lunch they
can't be [ __ ] dragging in a real
[ __ ] pine tree
it's upside down yeah uh no as you get
older obviously but growing up we had a
fake one and i
[ __ ] hated it one you had to like put
it together it was like the green level
the red level the
i'm like it took nine hours it looks
weird on the inside it looks like a
space station
it does dude a lot of docking going on
in that thing i was
not a fan no and then finally we're like
[ __ ] it danny can choke to death get to
go get the douglas fir
[ __ ] bring him back christmas joy to
him
was it was just buying for his scent
yeah i got my first real tree this year
with my girl
ah delightful experience it's great it's
christmas magic
it's great i was opposed my whole life
when i was like who gives a [ __ ] and i
went
i'm all in i put it through the net
machine oh
remember that when you were a kid i
wanted to get in there yeah
how has how has no like christmas
holiday villain
been vanquished with the net machine
yeah that's good you know like a home
alone three they tossed danny devito in
the [ __ ] thing
get netflix on the phone yeah are you
garbage christmas me and you save
christmas come on i'm in
any producers out there or anybody want
to give me 20 bucks
one of the other i gotta get a tree and
they're expensive in new york
you're that guy you haven't gotten a
tree yet i'm sorry we've been busy
for next year maybe bozo it's over if
you remind me you're leaving
what are you first of all i don't have
children you know
you have you're leaving tomorrow yeah i
still have [ __ ] you're only like nine
days
you want my tree no you're a holiday
shrub but no i'm going to get a big man
pajama
i got a big [ __ ] living room but i
tell you don't spend any money
dropping a [ __ ] big one whatever my
wife can afford i'll tell you that much
i got the biggest one they had but
that's my favorite thing in new york and
obviously
i just i i'm sorry to interrupt yeah
well you've been doing it all show but
continue
why didn't you get a tree earlier you're
supposed to put your christmas tree up
after thanksgiving days before
our recording schedule has been [ __ ]
bananas
because you're leaving you're leaving
for two weeks
so i don't have a christmas tree so you
go to [ __ ] hawaii and run around with
that girlfriend of yours and i
appreciate it yeah
so you getting by meanwhile you're
saying you got your [ __ ] feet up and
on my tie i'm still out here [ __ ]
taking enemy fire
what if kippy got that tree yet yeah
right
[ __ ] ah breaking my balls we're
recording 19 episodes a day so you could
go on vacation i'm sitting around a
bunch of fat guys in the beach think kid
you got the tree yeah yeah
well there's some more types of me and
my friends where's that patreon money
waiting for
[ __ ] you're gonna be like you're
gonna be like newman in the beginning of
jurassic park
yeah this is like this is the epitome of
our
relationship i'm like waking up in the
morning we're doing like 15 hours i'm
working hard too but i get the tree
after thanksgiving like a gentleman
yeah well i mean you're dude this second
we're done we're done recording tonight
for the rest of the year
and it's vacationable we're getting the
[ __ ] tree tomorrow we're hanging all
this [ __ ] we're doing it
[ __ ] right i just need to get all
this [ __ ] behind me hmm
does your your so your girl is german
she's german
are you gonna do any like german
christmasy things like do you have to
like put
gold in some sort of claw they do
something with shoes like
this i remember in french class they did
some [ __ ] where they put like toys
inside cake or something
yeah the germans they put change in
there yeah
it's like yo [ __ ] i ain't chipping my
tooth on a nickel for a [ __ ] piece of
bundt cake on a [ __ ] deutsche mark
yeah break the [ __ ] out of here man they
do
the germans do something with shoes i've
never really caught onto but it's like
you leave your shoes out and you put
popcorn in them comes and [ __ ]
even corbin schlopp father christmas and
[ __ ] who the [ __ ] that
but they do do they do these [ __ ]
christmas german christmas villages
where they [ __ ] it's like in the
because all their towns are like old
school towns right it's like yeah
they're from like the [ __ ] 1300s i
just realized i'm chewing gum i'm going
to take it out
um thanks for letting us know somebody
bitched about it
um so it's nicorette gum too
yeah that's how trashy is i'm almost i'm
so so let it go 15 minutes he's going to
be screaming at me i'm doing pretty good
with the no smoking
buddy i smoked i mean i don't know who
we're lying yeah i haven't given you six
all week
no i've had one or two here and i say no
like just give me a sig
like you're my dad one or two here and
there we had one after uh
well spend it however you want you had
like
i believe i will yeah sure things are
going well yeah
shout out to foley for quitting smoking
thank you german christmas village
do it nice it's like the heated wine and
it's all the [ __ ] treats it's [ __ ]
nice dude yeah i get that but does your
you're a big christmas i'm telling you
you would [ __ ] love it
it's [ __ ] fantastic i would like that
you get the hot [ __ ] i'm not pulling
nothing out of a shoe
no one's asking me i'm talking about the
german christmas villages hmm
yeah europeans do some weird [ __ ] over
there
krumpish over here krumpus crimpets
no he's like the wolf guy he's the wolf
man that comes around and gets you if
you're a bad kid
krampus krampus is that real yeah yeah
it was also the punchline of the show
about two minutes ago yeah i know zero
oh yeah what's the story i don't know
the story hey some like [ __ ] bigfoot
that goes around and [ __ ] up
kids that are bad a couple weeks before
christmas [ __ ] him up what are you
gonna beat them up
out of the movie i saw he was he was
killing people yeah so the the the deal
with krampus is that like in american
folklore if you're bad you get a lump of
coal and german folklore
hey [ __ ] you get rid of
yeah dude is the shadow of santa claus
comes down and steals
all the children and drags them to hell
yeah i don't like that shadow [ __ ]
no no i didn't even like santa i would
have been jewish i'd rather be jewish in
germany than the [ __ ] crap
yeah take my i'll take my shot with the
nazis
[ __ ] that i'll wrote a dice in his
brisket yeah good it is you and your
shadow monster can hit the [ __ ]
bricks dude dude
i swear to god i love i love santa claus
more now than i did when i was a kid
well let's
uh let's get uh we gotta we gotta we
gotta [ __ ] tighten the ship here a
lot we got a lot to go over so we're
having a nice time christmas oh we were
right just relax well this is what we're
doing what do you think i'm
to start talking about taxes what are we
doing i got christmas stuff i don't want
to talk about taxes
yeah march march is coming quick yeah um
i'm going to punt that another year i
don't
claim the pandemic i'm a veteran for
god's sake um
krampus got me
is that it can i check that box on my
[ __ ] tax return
shout out to krampus uh
what are we doing presents what's going
on with you i went over the run of the
show like nine minutes ago what you need
are your boys your blood sugar low again
i feel great it's just christmas time
and now i want presents
i was up at 5 30 pacing the hallways
let's [ __ ] go every morning every
christmas how
when did you stop believing in santa
claus let's get to the [ __ ]
nitty-gritty of this first of all we got
a lot of questions to get to from the
patreon on facebook like i said we got a
[ __ ] and then plus we got it me and
full we got presents for each other we
stuffed our stockings
but you got me a black and white one
what the [ __ ] hit the bricks with that
i was last minute yeah it's probably
your old sock that's all they had
i was gonna i was gonna do that too i
almost bought a pair of socks and cbs
but they weren't just shoved like a bar
so
that was the last one they had a foot
locker that's a prescription
i was going to get you compression socks
too but i have compressions
my mom got him i know had him laying on
my bed you know like a regular grown man
yeah mommy can you give me compression
shots no she just dude
i can't feel my toes she's she's so
[ __ ]
on point and i'll admit that i'm spoiled
in that regard
she's so on point like we got there that
day bed was made fresh
[ __ ] everything was sitting right in
that i love when she's be weird if you
showed up and there's no sheets on the
bed
i mean what's on a motel six what the
[ __ ] there better be if you're showing
up to your mom's house
you think that's spoiling you oh look at
it
she even [ __ ] put the windows back in
it was just gonna stay with this
yeah she's good with that stuff um how
old were you when you
when you stopped believing in santa
claus or found out about santa claus i
still believe in santa claus
i realize what real what the real santa
claus is now
you're the real santa claus i'm the real
santa claus toby's the real santa claus
all those dads and uncles and all that
stuff out there and ants
they're the real santa clauses it's a
spirit it's an idea it's a [ __ ]
it's a movement okay going back to the
question i asked
how old were you when you freaking found
out santa claus wasn't real 15. what are
you are you running for mayor or the
north pole or something what's with
these answers i can't be in a good mood
and have a good time
yes you can but i ask you when you stop
believing in santa claus you're like
well actually that's a funny question
you bring that up
great question mr kippy uh actually blah
blah blah blah
i don't know man uh hello i'm sorry am i
bothering you with this line of
questioning
i don't know man what are we doing here
11 12 i would say
yeah i cuz we we we stumbled across
um a bunch of [ __ ] i've been to our
house there's not a lot of places to
hide it
this is when we were living in town line
in the townhouse well you can't
townhouse kids find out early oh yeah
she well she packed it my mom put all
the press
put a blanket over a new bike don't look
at that that ain't yours don't go in the
living room
for the next three weeks what are you
painting
um no she stacked them all in the in the
dining room
and and she went to and they were just
but no names on them she drilled good
yeah it could be for could be for the
aunts and uncles or cousins whatever
yeah um
but uh then one night she went to work
and uh my dad was away
and i was sitting there and my brother
walked in with a brand new pair of
sneakers
i was like dude where'd you get that
there's a box up there
he's like he's like come here and he
figured he took a razor blade and slit
the
the scotch tape in ocean's eleven what
the [ __ ]
dude i looked at him i thought he was
genius yeah doing it he comes down on a
rope
i was like who are you man [ __ ] seal
team booney over there
but uh yeah he slipped the things we
sold all of our presents out we looked
at all of them
we put them back perfectly nice haul he
got skis
i gotta say how do you hide a set of
skis in the dining room of a townhouse
he found the boots he's going to
schooling on the next day
he found the boots um and then a couple
days later we came home from school
and my dad was there he was supposed to
be in like [ __ ] new orleans or
something like that
sitting there full navy uniform [ __ ]
smoking at the kitchen table
piss yeah piss talk about ruining
christmas ah
we ruined everything yeah vacations
i don't know how they did it honestly i
would have [ __ ] been gone
he's like i'm like what's going on
where's mom he's like she's over at your
aunts balling her eyes out
to your mob boss you know what she
is she's in the hospital right now ac
says ten percent
um you know that's from now angels with
filthy souls at home alone
oh yeah yeah um deep cut who goes with
that line i just watched it last night i
told you we're watching christmas movies
yeah it's on the brains
yeah go with the high heat you're giving
me the [ __ ] deep cuts on a non on a
fictional movie
also a way to know the name of the fake
movie i am
talk about that guy oh that guy's great
mm-hmm um
john hughes shout out shout out that's
right chicago
chicago oh thank you lake shore drive
they filmed it over there
i drove by the house one time
sure you and your bozo pals are one of
them all smoked up in an old fiat went
out front in the park
ran out from the front lawn and sort of
danced like michael jordan
cardboard cutout whatever so
we got busted so we got nothing sure
so christmas morning woke up but she go
return everything no probably
get [ __ ] to get flushed with a little
bit of cage these fat bozos aren't going
skiing anyway
by the way you weren't a skiing family
what were they for the yard
you guys couldn't afford lift tickets i
told you we went to sprint brothers
started skiing for a hot minute
in his jeans he had jeans and gators
remember those things that
those like little they were like
windbreaker material they were four but
they were four dirt balls
who skied in their jeans they were like
little like uh and they switched
did they sing yeah and they came up like
to your knee
oh i thought they were so cool yeah um
and yeah we opened all of our [ __ ] that
morning and they were uh
it was all filled with dirty clothes
dirty clothes yeah she filled all the
boxes with dirty clothes yo your
parents are freaked out [ __ ] up and
then eventually like some [ __ ] little
whitey titties with skidmarks in them
and then eventually they
later that day they gave us everything
after
now you are [ __ ] up after a couple
complete meltdowns oh my god
hey what's up everybody quick
announcement from our sponsor today
favorite sponsor sheath underwear dot
com they've been a [ __ ] supporter of
the show for a long time so
check them out big supporter of podcasts
in general
yeah a lot of people got sheet underwear
as ads on their podcast
and i'll tell you why because they're
fantastic that's why
if you buy anything off the podcast make
sure it's a pair of sheath underwear
they're unbelievable
especially technologically designed to
separate the franks and the beans
if you want or you just got to pair a
nice underwear
yeah they're fantastic they feel great
it's the only underwear i'll wear
multiple days in a row they don't smell
they don't lose shape hey you put them
on it on day five it's like putting on a
brand new set of dreams i feel like
batman when i put them on
i dude you look better and plus you know
me and the big man they make you look a
little
more well endowed than you actually are
smoking mirrors baby
yeah i'll run and get the mail in these
things you know what i mean i'm out i'm
out fro
i'm out front smoking cigs just showing
it off to the neighbors a little bit
i'll go to the post office wearing them
i'll tell you that right now i don't
care
so go to sheathunderware.com use promo
code garbage
and get a discount and you'll be
supporting the podcast we get to wet our
beaks a little bit
that sheath underwear dot com promo code
garbage
now back to the show yeah i can be
pretty persuasive
jesus christ [ __ ] denying little fat
foley of his toys
they were in for a [ __ ] hell of a day
they like tantrums oh
dude you throw a tantrum now when you
don't get your way at 44. i couldn't
imagine you would not get in [ __ ]
monopoly
what's the best present you've ever
received um
straight up so my parents split i would
say the fans of this podcast
love you guys it's [ __ ] merry
christmas sometimes he just gets in
these weird moods where i
i can't read them i don't know what's
happening
chestnuts roasting on an open fire yeah
he's got scratchers on the brain
um best gift i ever got was so my
parents divorced and my dad was
obviously my dad always went big to like
you know my brother
the one year [ __ ] to talk about a
talk about a dad trying to outshine a
[ __ ] single mom
what would you do we'd wake up in the
morning at your mom's at my mom's
do presents then you always claim like i
did presents as a kid
the night before sure
the other day thank god we lost the
recording you really [ __ ] try
in the intro like this guy blah blah
blah making me look like you don't like
that [ __ ] yeah well why do you why don't
[ __ ] on you in the opening of the intro
i'm gonna start
you you make up for it for most of the
episode though and in real life yeah and
comedy but you really
[ __ ] no you really need one i love
you what do you mean without you what
would i be doing
um my uh we'd wake up we'd do presents
at my mom's
is the other guy there yeah yeah my
stepdad was there
from an early he would he wouldn't stay
there earlier how long
how long before he was rolling in the
front door
not long before he was sleeping there
from when the divorce was
i don't know three weeks four weeks what
are you talking about
the ink wasn't dry no i i i was so young
i don't remember
but really yeah i mean they got divorced
when i was like three or something um
a couple of years after that i think so
he would come in the morning it was
before he was sleeping there
wow so he would come early at like seven
o'clock in the morning shout out to the
step dads that's a tough look
[ __ ] coming and
and [ __ ] who's this guy yeah opening
other people's presents i was a [ __ ]
wreck so i [ __ ]
oh so a little kippy we would we would
do my mom we were
hanging out of your mouth we would do
christmas dinner rolls
we would have breakfast we would just be
christmas dinner rolls at 7am so we
would do open the presents at my mom's
and then sometimes they would team up
and allude to a present i was going to
get in my dad's because i called my
your mom and dad i caught my dad when i
was still somewhat okay
yeah it was for the kids i mean they
kept yeah you know they kept up
appearances for us i'm sure they hated
each other but
when i called my dad when he was still
living that so i was like three and i
called him bringing down presents from
the attic
and i was like what are you doing and he
hit me with like i walked on him and my
mom like [ __ ] haven't she's like yeah
go back to bed you know what i mean and
i'm like back
i'm like what are you doing dude he's
like i'm helping so he's got a [ __ ]
stack full of presents coming down from
the attic i'm like what are you doing
he's like i'm helping santa i'm like yo
i was already suspect about this whole
[ __ ] charade as it is
[ __ ] you gotta get up pretty early in
the morning go back and throw the
cookies out
yeah yeah so the dish in the sink i know
from a young age i knew so they would
allude to like a big present i would get
on my dad's so like the one year
my brother got a go-kart and i got a
mini bike
and does it get any more dress than that
but we got the helmets with our names on
them
at my mom's like we got like custom
[ __ ] like race car helmets tell me
you still have that
you've got to have that somewhere i
don't know that's got to be in here i
gotta see it we might
i i was this hot rod it was that same
it was it was the same one from dumb and
dumb or the little red one that he
that they drive oh that's what i got on
like seven my brother got a goat
seven and i could yeah so i thought you
could ride there no i crashed at the
first i got on my dad i was like i was
like dude let's [ __ ] go let's [ __ ]
take me to the [ __ ]
seven take me to the went to this big
empty parking lot on christmas day
and i made it [ __ ] like 10 feet and i
couldn't it's like you just hit the you
rev the engine and i
i don't know i'm [ __ ] gunning it at a
big cardboard dumpster
like at a big dumpster for cardboard why
don't you try it in a field not on
asphalt i don't know so i [ __ ] dump
the bike i just [ __ ]
get [ __ ] road burn all over my
[ __ ] arms
go home the next day and i'm sitting
there my mom's like what happened to you
and i'm like i've
a lot it's the first time i got caught
lying to my mom and said i fell off the
monkey bars and she goes
that don't happen she's like you're
lying to me that don't happen from
monkey bars i'm like
i
looks like i had dragged behind a car
for an hour and i said the monkey bars
got me
oh man well i found out early but they
used to do wait did you scratch up the
bike or that so you [ __ ] up the
president
that would have been a problem if i
broke anything christmas morning
it wasn't it was it was an issue it was
a serious i mean it was like i mean
it's a little it's not like i broke a
puzzle like i [ __ ] i thought my dad
was more concerned that
was the pain up was he was like a
[ __ ] 300 dollar mini bike
he never wrote it wasn't a ducati or
anything it's like
it's not like he got me a harley it was
like [ __ ] 300 bucks big saddle bags
on the side but i [ __ ] loved that
thing dude
did you take it did you use it again
yeah yeah for years drove it okay
yeah i gotta find that helmet i took it
to prom
get on tuts you gotta find that helmet
but what he i knew he would keep the big
present he would always get a big prezi
we keep that in the empty we talked
about this on the one episode he keep
that in the empty living room
or like the living room okay like the
dining room didn't have a table in it
so like i'm like i know so i know i'm
getting something
so like i waddle over to like i open up
the presents and i'm like there's still
something big
you're always killing time till the big
one yeah i know you knew it i feel it in
the air dude where's the oh yeah hit me
with the [ __ ] zinger let's go my
parents are good they'd pull it out of
the couch they'd
well there's one more thing santa let's
go like oh yeah
um yours was a ham uh so i like scallop
potatoes i
walked over to the fridge to be like i'm
just gonna get a drink so i could peek
into the dining room and sure
[ __ ] she was sitting there really hog
did you have to wait and go through the
on ceremony with the guy they rolled it
out
and i was like yeah whatever i don't
know so your dad had a motorcycle in his
living room
the trap i think it was a dining room
that didn't have a table in it
technically wow
yeah that's garbage where he used to
play knee football remember
get on it dude especially around the
holidays yeah my dad would take my dad
thought he was back in his [ __ ]
semi-pro days dude he would [ __ ]
truck us
[ __ ] put my head through a wall knee
football was great
yeah all right um you want to get to the
presents and then we'll do some
questions yeah yeah let's do presents
all right here you go i
uh okay wait do i want you to open yours
why would you open my presents no i mean
what did you guys do
here all right i mean i want you to open
no yeah you open your second i'll open
mine okay
either way you bought it what was the
price limit on this well i think i found
one thing
i spent a grand hang on wait
all right can i give toby sure let's
give toby his first t-bone
t-bone you you had mentioned uh a
certain film on the podcast
so i got you all we got you we got you
all the cars from fast and the furious
yeah dawg
right [ __ ] rules yeah can i throw it
over here
watch the cameras merry christmas buddy
we love you
merry christmas pal thanks for your hard
work yeah that is your raise for the
year
all right good job boy who's who needs
the in-ground pool
i got a [ __ ] charger on the [ __ ]
desk
yeah man we'll put some back here too i
figured yeah damn
shout out shout out paul walker i know
you're on it i know you're on a diet
you're watching
what that's the [ __ ] diet food well
yeah i was gonna put it i was gonna put
an onion in there there's gonna be a
mini bike in there inside of that door
i'm gonna freak out move the couch it's
a new car
it's a scale and a life alert
i see one [ __ ] thing that says keto
on it uh
i you know i got you so i got you some
well they were at checkout
cashews kind of that was a filler i'm an
impulse buy that was a filler
that was a those are sugar-free russell
stover
sugar-free come on that's pretty good
he's like [ __ ] hoodie you're turning
me into toady over here what do you mean
start playing bingo my aunt mary captain
used to [ __ ] with uh
these sugar-free candies and when you
would not realize it and grab one of
those instead of a real worthers
uh take the skin off the top of your
mouth i don't know what chemicals
they're using
um but i figured you're a big chocolate
candy guy i figured that's in the
wheelhouse it's a little bit of a cheap
one okay
come on wow you spent money you're gonna
be disappointed big man's going on a
trip i got an inflatable neck pillow
neck pillow come on 9.99 not too bad
see what else we got here whoa a car
come on that's pretty cool you're a big
toy guy
great yeah i love it it's zipped off the
[ __ ] cash register i didn't realize
it was a wind-up one
pretty sweet thank you buddy see what
else
i know you're going away with your lady
so i got them
so i got it it's adamandeve.com i got
him a personal tub of vaseline
huh i know he can get dry in these cold
months beg my own self huh
go down to the beach some tummies thank
tom's cause he's got a big acid reflux
problem
that might be it all right the rest is
just bad i was worried oh man
hey when i [ __ ] in the street thanks man
those are the bags it came in at a 12
and a stocking that was 12.99
all right great nice i feel good about
this i just saw one thing in your
stocking and i think you might have just
filled it with things you want by the
way
[Laughter]
he got me a thing of [ __ ] helmets
that's probably expired what's the date
on this no it's fresh
all right that's a real good gift right
there yeah you got me some helmets
this is all just stuff in your car i
think what are you talking about
because he's also got me honey mustard
barbecue sauce and
hot mustard this is all stuff you want
that's the trio right there
did you go to mcdonald's today no when
did you go
i went and i bought those specifically
you can't you can't yes you can i have
the receipt of my car i went and bought
a bunch of them
i had about 19 cheeseburgers i had to
buy i had to buy see that receipt
i will i'll show it to you it's out of
the car i had to buy four of each sauce
if i wanted to make to make the
transaction
so where are the other sauces i decided
to figure i'd only bring a few of them
for you
i'm not gonna eat them oh fully i'm
telling you
four of each sauce so there's three
sauces so that means he's
he's got nine other sauces somewhere at
a minimum
minimum he's got nine other sauces i
think we threw them away or crystal has
them hidden somewhere
dreidel treats your wife's jewish got
you a little you know
something for the other side thank you
it's got little candies in it
okay i think that's it no there's
something else
oh yeah this is your big present
a big mama jimmy york peppermint patty
i remember in the summer when kippy went
down to the shure on the old episodes we
were doing them on the zoom and
quarantine check them out on youtube
oh man you stumbled across a bag of
those in the back of the freezer
dude these will blow your [ __ ] hair
but since i can't have him anymore i
want you to i want you to have
they all are things that i can't have
anymore that i would like you to enjoy
except for the mayonnaise the only way
to eat a york peppermint patty is to
take a little bite and then suck it out
like you're
like you're a you're sucking the brain
out of a [ __ ] insect with your wait
the juice out yeah yeah you bite and
then you suck the inside out
just kids from chicago these chicago
guys are bonkers no you're just you're
just biting straight across
well i like them in the freezer or
they're [ __ ] real nice
what are you eating this guy's already
eating candy
hey tubsy come on we're doing a podcast
here he just
the sugar-free is no good all right then
give them back
give them back give them back not
actually who takes a present eats it
because this present sucks
what was it putting here pretty good
i switched out the labels it's actually
sugar alcohol it's the real stuff i just
want nobody to get mad
i know a guy at the factory he
mislabeled a couple for me
the big man needs his stuff you know
what i've got to keep the big man happy
now what i would do now thank you very
much merry christmas
i love you mm-hmm i love you both is now
merry christmas guys
what would happen is it would be some
sort of quiche that would be served to
the family
okay my parents would break off my dad
would go watch tv my mom or whatever
and me and my brother and each side of
the living room
would then create our presentation of
presents
presents weren't allowed to get taken
upstairs right away they had to sit
there for a couple of days
so when people came over they could see
the presents
so your job was to set things up on the
boxes like put the sneakers out like a
display
set your gi joes up real nice best
present i ever got gi joe headquarters
and it was the year my house got robbed
and i thought that's what they took
that who broke in 11 year olds
you know little rascals meanwhile like
they got your mom's [ __ ] wedding ring
the safe deposit box thank god my gi
joe basis dude i did my mom was crying
her eyes out cause they told they took
her uh
her mom's diamond necklace dude as you
guys were opening your presents i don't
know if you noticed but you said the
price of everything which
is hilarious to me did we pretty much i
did
i gotta flex something i spent more than
you yeah well you got to do the neck
pillow
having to display your children's gifts
to flex that is [ __ ] great bring it
over the neighbors take a look at that
that's a starter jacket right there
i went to three different stores to get
that thing right that's the real
cabbage patch kid right there not the
radicchio guys
that's trash also so we did it one
i it was i forget where it was brought
up but somebody brought up
wearing the new clothes that day what of
course i know but you're supposed to i
know but you show up to dinner or
whatever you still go
it looks like you got the hanger in your
back
everything's got the [ __ ] creases and
the folds
some of your cousins got the sticker on
his chest the jeans say 3434 on the back
[ __ ] you drove it off the lot baby here
we go
you look like a real jamoke dealer tags
in the back of your shirt
yeah you look like a real idiot when
you're wearing that present that day
ah dude i showed up to so many christmas
dinners that my
hand she was with like the jeans rolled
back up
[ __ ] four inches yeah they were too
big [ __ ] sleeves hanging over your
hands you look like an idiot
i remember i showed up dude as an adult
like some picky ass sweater just like oh
i was i was an adult i was like 20 i was
probably i was in college i was probably
20 and i showed up to my cousin's house
that night like i drove over and i got
like new polo black or whatever and i
like
you know i diced myself doused myself in
the polo black three or four spritzes
i show up i hug my cousin at the door
goes well someone got cologne i was like
oh man i'm a [ __ ] idiot
hide the car you just checked out uh one
more thing real quick before we get into
the
uh the listener questions sure uh do you
have any traditions like
like foley you said christmas quiche at
my house it was corn chowder we'd always
have because
this kid's a [ __ ] hillbilly well it
was because my dad hated it or no
it was either corn shot or split pea
soup i don't remember but how did he get
those two mixed things what are you guys
homeless
who does split pea who does soup it just
might have been hot water i'm literally
no no it was split pea soup my dad hated
split pea soup so my mom was like i'll
make it a tradition
so i can guarantee myself those poopy
soup
soup my favorite dish of the year
and they made this special that about
the time ebenezer scrooge bounced in
and made it rain in there scorch [ __ ]
bob cratchit over here did you eat it
out of tupperware
jesus my mom tried to give me soup on
[ __ ] christmas
uh it was a [ __ ] four course i'd
start with a soup you have a salad you
have a mane
i could soup croutons and water four
course meals i'd convert the muslim if i
had to
what was your favorite uh present you
ever got best present i ever got hands
down
was that soup was this soap it was
my chicago bear's jersey
[Laughter]
shout out to erlacker best guy in the
game i tell you what i was walking into
zany's rosemont for the first time
[Laughter]
[Applause]
uh shout out to brian he's all done
though another story
uh best gift i ever got hands down no
question uh my after the first year i
was dating my girl
together like almost five years now uh
she got me
my first like professional camera ah
that's pretty good
yeah it was like hvx 200 panasonic
unbelievable nice it's a bit it was like
because i'd always talked about wanting
to get a video and blah blah blah
and then she was the first person to
ever like facilitate that that's cool
i was broke at the time wow shut up i'm
broke now what are we talking about this
is all this
this is all the [ __ ] smoking that's
your poinsettias though uh
yeah 9.99 nice gonna return them
sell them on the street you ever cried
christmas cause you got something
no that camera made me cry straight up
really straight up you still talk to
this bro
what yeah i'd live with her oh oh she
the love of his life i thought it was an
old guy i thought you said your first
girlfriend or something no no no sam
oh that's a keeper right there oh she's
the greatest hang on to that
i love it she also got me that never
mind it doesn't matter
no tell me grand theft auto oh no she
she's the best best christmas presents
ever can't be what about you
you brought up crying and i'm not
somebody i don't i don't want to
overstep it because i want to give them
credit this dude uh roman from the
facebook group says you ever receive an
ipad from your brother-in-law
but you're drunk and for some reason you
just start bawling your eyes out in
front of the whole family
dude that it's so cool that's such a
deep cut
oh boy buddy i get it it's been a long
year you don't feel loved
someone [ __ ] fit someone drops a
[ __ ] eye busy on you
good night let the waterworks fly oh
man crying around people you don't want
to cry around is a real vulnerable dude
but once you get that out it feels so
good that's [ __ ] awesome
what the [ __ ] wrong with danny you
said this guy was cool
i don't know what was it what was it
actually an ipad
yeah yeah i got an ipad from your
brother-in-law so i assume he's at the
other part he's at the other half of the
family he's not even at his own place
that's great he's on enemy territory
yikes
that's [ __ ] trash yeah let's get into
uh some patreon questions let's do it
let's do it um this is a [ __ ] home
run that's
big at the ryan [ __ ] kelly household
here
ah this is from will campbell in the
patreon
what about those fake fireplaces people
put on the tv
[Laughter]
it's called a yule log you go to like
channel 898 and it's three hours of a
yule log
yeah we're big on the tv
that's on every tv in the house look at
the smoke detector ain't going off
we got that thing playing loud
[Music]
we used to do the proper fire but then
the kids there's just too many little
kids and then you're looking at that
what's real trash is back you know
before there was little kids i mean
because there's
[ __ ] six drunk adults there's six
kids now all under
you know seven so there's just too many
[ __ ] you can't you know you can't have
the fire going plus
i'll say this unless you live in [ __ ]
antarctica that fire's cool for about
the first hour
then you got [ __ ] two pounds of
turkey or ham or hors d'oeuvres in you
and you're trying to sit in the living
room and eat your dessert with something
four eyepieces
and a [ __ ] wool sweater that don't
fit yeah that thing saw open the back
open the screen door will ya
that's when you got to go out to the
back porch and rip a bernie
and then you come in wreaking like butts
yeah dude
smoking cigs in the cold weather and
coming in
it's like being [ __ ] cryogenically
frozen that shit's tough and it stinks
um i uh [ __ ] the fire but we used a
real trashy do we used to burn the
[ __ ]
the wrapping paper we would just throw
it in there and [ __ ] torch it up
[ __ ] shredding like yeah like we was
like [ __ ] home home on the range
it's a good idea though oh christmas day
we would go to my uncle's place
and he would uh we'd have a big
breakfast and he'd always get uh
bojangles biscuits
which is fast food i know right but the
thing about it is it's
no there's no thing about it those
biscuits are better than any biscuit you
could ever make at home they're
unbelievable biscuits
these biscuits are incredible i'll hear
it i'll hear no sign [ __ ] mcdonald's
makes a hell of a [ __ ] burger we're
not having burgers on [ __ ]
and we'd wrap them in wrap them in tin
foil with some with some ham from the
night before
and some cheese toss them in the fire
get them nice and toasty
pull that [ __ ] out wait you're really
cooking on the in the fireplace
[ __ ] yeah dude toby's giving it up today
man he really is he's letting us really
know that
we're cooking on a bonfire and eating
soup tin foil what are you freebasing
[ __ ]
uh you've never been camping throw throw
some food in tin foil
yeah i don't camp in the living room or
on christmas
ah it's the best ah sounds good though
yeah ham and cheddar biscuit i like it
fire i don't like the mechanism of it
this is this is from jeff on the patreon
uh
matching pajamas question mark
he goes my wife makes the four of us all
dress up which i caught this is
i think if you're if you're like a
newlywed couple
and you got a new kid you know a couple
of young
two tree four or five year it's like
it's fun it's fun for them it's fun for
the kids if you're doing it
or do you do i feel like you might do
this no no
no it's weird to me we never did it it's
like
i don't know we're like too childish
we're running around like a teenager
who's just like your mom
we usually have a christmas party every
year my cousins and all our friends and
family come
every every couple years there'll be a a
pajama one where it's like everybody
wear their
pajamas for tomorrow was it school
spirit week who does that something like
that yeah everyone will dress up you
know like you know showing up and
everybody's [ __ ]
it was just flopping around the [ __ ] out
of here
yeah see i don't want to see your
[ __ ] uncle steve's piece flopping
around when he gets up to get booze you
wear undergarments
it was when those old navy flannels
became hot
family she's five years ago whose family
does pajama parties
[Laughter]
lingerie
[Laughter]
teddy's for the girls um but another
thing
christmas eve as a kid at the foley's
we go out to the car to go to midnight
mass is when we were really young
got to the car to go midnight mass my
mom stays inside for a second she puts
two fresh pair
of pajamas on my bed and on my brother's
bed
old school ones like the button ups so
we looked good for the christmas
pictures in the morning
that's a little bit right there how old
were you though
uh she did it she did it up i was in my
20s when she was still doing it man
but my brother had already had his own
place and stuff so it was just me
but we really yeah we still dress up in
the pajamas what part of you
as a man goes ma i can't do this
[ __ ] your brother's moved out he's got a
she was breaking me oh you're still
dressing up
she was breaking oh this guy will do
anything for a buck if he knows that
if he knows there's going to be a couple
of scratches coming down the steps do
the funny faces
oh yeah man go to the mall get a picture
with santa and the dog i'd do it all
baby
man you are the shell of a man hired for
the holidays
yeah i was working at christmas my girl
got us matching pajamas this year
and let me tell you what hilarious love
it
i always say that that's a guy in love
yeah meanwhile you're just eating soup
on christmas so anything's [ __ ] nice
for you
can i say this one of my soup out of the
nice china guys come on the soup it was
good soup homemade soup
split pea that's depression error [ __ ]
too you know [ __ ] get some french
onion class it up a little bit a little
bit slice and precise and provolone
treat yourself through the bag of pieces
[ __ ] bowl of gruel holiday tradition
at the mcmullen ah my favorite goulash
got a scottish roots there um
those uh those onesies that the ladies
wear
you know they're like with the back flap
let me tell you something about easy
access you know what i mean let me tell
you something
about that back flap one of my most
erotic moments
when i was in college with my girlfriend
she wore one of the i'd never seen this
on an adult before
and then she came down christmas eve
that in a pacifier
maybe a rattle diaper whatever you need
to get you going big man hey it's 20 20.
i don't judge
no it wasn't a christmas onesie she was
like dressed like a prospect
[Laughter]
pair of long johns and a little mini
shovel
she had a sifter and a pot one gold
tooth bowling it down the steps
[ __ ] her in a wagon um no man
hey penthouse chronicles we gotta get
through this we gotta get through these
questions
what are you busting my balls we're
having a good time every time i know i
made a joke
relax you do you can't take it personal
honestly this thing was hot
yeah also i don't need to hear about you
and some [ __ ] lady and
lady and [ __ ] pj's going at it okay
what the [ __ ] this is a [ __ ] pg
episode this is the christmas
this is aunt tony's basement meanwhile
you're [ __ ] reliving this
you're reliving [ __ ] fantasy days
pornhub chill out will you come on
i gotta get back into the [ __ ] you
know talk about tim allen's the santa
claus i think i get loose on the
christmas special
somebody got into the eggnog the
network's gonna be all over us
ah we can breeze through this this is
from uh don't breathe
or anything we got all day i know what
i'm doing relax i know what i'm doing
it's christmas i know we have like we
literally have like
60 [ __ ] really good things i want to
get to excellent i'll be quiet
i don't want you to be quiet this is a
podcast i also don't need you to talk
about you tugging on your little root
it's the second time you brought it up
it was sexy sexiest thing i've ever been
involved in
what are considered trash stocking
stuffers obviously you go
lotto tickets that's probably the trash
coconut cashews and vaseline
i know it's going to get you in the mood
oh yeah you can pop into the bathroom
between apps
um i i would what were your go
to what what did you always get in stock
we always got cologne
batteries for like whatever remote
control like whatever we
got it was always like the accessory
because they're making the batteries its
own present that's gorgeous no in the
stockings
still so philadelphia christmas in case
the [ __ ] j-max
are [ __ ] cowboys are in town you
gotta [ __ ] tune someone up right
quick
nine volts were the best uh no it was
always like you know it was
scratchers it was scratchers
we didn't get lottery tickets the foleys
we did we were true yeah i mean my stuff
that we were big we're presenting at the
foleys
you're a 25 year old man in pajamas so
you can get 50 bucks out of your mom you
ain't presenting nothing
that was 75. it was 75 at christmas and
a wawa gift card
75 a photo if i did photos outside it
was 100.
what'd you get in the stocking there big
man cologne watches
um socks was big in there
hand warmers i don't know why always
with the hammer yeah that was the hand
warmers
i go from the house to the bus to the
[ __ ] home room you drive me to school
i make sure you pre-heat the car before
i get in too oh yeah that was always an
issue
i send her out there why are you
finishing up my apples and cinnamon
oatmeal i used to be pissed on the way
to school when the car was cold it was
only like four minutes i'm like it's not
even gonna be warm by the [ __ ] time i
get to see oh yeah i'd send her out
there hey get the car warmed up and
throw stern on will you i got a long day
ahead of me
see what robin's yapping about uh sorry
get the [ __ ] fourth grade
this is just this is like this is a
trashy tradition from victoria make no
mistake doesn't want to be
sent to the back victoria
my pop-pop takes down the christmas tree
during christmas
oh during christmas dinner because he
and my mom i'm leaving for florida the
next day
why even bother buddy just [ __ ]
cut out a picture of one or something
setting it up and taking there's a man
who doesn't regret having a family
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] that's a man who drinks his
coffee black wow
no frills with that takes down i wonder
if it was a real tree
because that's even worse he drags it
out the front door whips it into the
[ __ ]
street neighbor comes out and takes it
still got a couple hours
johnson's already got rid of the tree
damn that's hardcore that's [ __ ] up
um yeah they go down to florida
this is uh me and me and t-bone we've
debated this a little bit this is from
stephen whitmer on the patreon does your
family watch die hard during christmas
and call it a christmas movie if so
trash
i believe die hard is a christmas movie
um we don't
my parents never really got into it
irrefutable i watch it every year
with my family with my favorite bowl of
soup my big old bowl of
split pea and or clam or corn chowder
soup i love die hard around the holidays
i love lethal weapon around the holidays
uh and um but my debate is it's not
about christmas it just takes place
around christmas right i think the way
the story goes i could be wrong the guy
who wrote i think all these movies shane
black but
again i could be wrong he purposely
likes to set
things around christmas just he thinks
it's interesting but when i picture a
christmas movie
it's like it's a storyline right it's
about the holidays it's about learning a
lesson about what the holiday is
the santa claus [ __ ] elf [ __ ] the
grinch [ __ ]
takes place
yeah yeah i mean if you're watching
[ __ ] buildings blow up on christmas
california that's a great um uh the
movies that made us on netflix
movies that made us and the toys that
made us [ __ ] phenomenal
movies that made us is great and they
have die hard it's a great story you
know it was originally
supposed to play uh bruce willis part i
do but i forget
frank sinatra because it was the second
book of this guy who wrote a book in the
[ __ ] 60s that became a movie
that sinatra was in so even though
sinatra was in like his 70s at the time
he still got first refusal i swear to
god
imagine that with [ __ ] synapses fly
me to the moon
you're coming bastard baby
[Laughter]
all right this is uh this is from jordan
i don't think that you know
this this is just not where we grew up
growing up did you
ever have a dish on holiday that was
consisted of wild game
ours was squirrel jesus
that ain't good that ain't good for
business see it
sounded too bad now get me a bowl of
soup
yo 86 the squirrel get me the split beat
yeah i get i guess split p's a treat
when you're eating [ __ ] mongoose the
rest of the year
holy [ __ ] squirrel meat um we would have
a neighbor that would go hunting
because uh you know pennsylvania where
we live there's a lot of hunters
sure mixed in there um
would show up with some venison yeah
that was so
my not too shabby my uh my
brother-in-law
his family's from like upstate
pennsylvania like you know
uh you know the sticks kind of sticks
and so
and we're a lot of white dodge rams
driving we were more
uh we were more city folk you know what
i mean suburbs but city-centric [ __ ]
people like nobody ever hunted or
anything and then my sister the first
time she
was except for perks
she went up too you got him she went up
to uh
her my brother-in-law's place for
christmas and her
dad popped at a vhs like him gutting a
deer being look
look at this eight-point deer my sister
sent us a text like these people are
[ __ ] up i was like yeah dude we don't
do we were never hunters or anything
i'd rather have that though than [ __ ]
pop-up taking down the christian
straight lamb yeah
why am i lapping up some ambrosia yeah
you know what i'm saying um this is from
mr krichner the sun god
uh have you ever had extended family nod
off during a family christmas
celebration
no but that would have been me now
now i've i've poked around when i got to
the house
see if anybody had any recent surgeries
or procedures you did that when we shot
the cribs episode
you were poking and probably i just do
that anyway just take an inventory yeah
see what's going on
generic see who's taking what i did
lipitor
you nodded out yeah on what i was
[ __ ] riding the lightning what do you
think
it wasn't candy canes dummy i was like
24 and i went down to my
folks place in florida uh and the
christmas eve dinner was a disaster my
parents were fighting the whole time
because my mom was offer meds yes
and the apartment complex they were in
had a big courtyard and everyone
in the place was meeting up to like have
drinks whatever
uh so they all go out and my mom's like
and you're gonna be out there
and you're going to have smiles on and
dips so i'm just standing there my dad
just silently makes a martini and walks
out there and i'm like god my mom is off
her meds and i was like oh [ __ ] my mom's
off her beds
there's meds so i go yeah
take a couple shots grab a beer go out
go outside and there's like
25 what were they what were the pills i
don't remember yeah
miscellaneous yeah i like it
yeah it was enough that i was like that
i was like oh this is gonna be bad for
my liver
and i go out and i'm like shucking and
jiving
[ __ ] hey how you been mr [ __ ] for
the first 15 minutes
dude fully black out right wake up in my
bed like oh no
what the [ __ ] did i do and the next
morning everyone in the building is
getting together
having [ __ ] lunch breakfast whatever
i walk in there i'm like
so ashamed i'm like oh god and then
people turn and look at me
and it was like chappelle walking in to
film a special i'm getting fist bumps
and bats on the back
i blacked out i crushed ah that's funny
we never
so there's the cue through his mom in
the pool man
t-bone you love me t-bone dude's badass
man
[Laughter]
i do rips dude parties
i don't know where he got them fireworks
from god damn
that manager was pissed we have we had
one
section of our extended family i'm not
gonna get too
uh intricate in details where some of
the people uh
had issues with substance abuse and
hey the opioid epidemic touched
everybody touched a lot of people
um so this was an extended thing and my
mom was at this party
and uh the one guy at the party would
give everybody some pretty hefty [ __ ]
td bank gift cards
right like everybody got whacked off
with like a 200 spot or like a three
four hundred spike i had a little bit of
key
so he would whack everybody off with
their own like td and they used to come
in like the green boxes or whatever
um so like he did that before and then
my
oh he's coming into chris's party
whacking everybody off
we had an old uncle that had it was cash
envelopes yeah and he kept it in his
pocket
all night and everybody's everybody's
clock in the pocket oh
clock so [ __ ] up i know you'd walk in
today with 60 70 bucks
at christmas that wasn't bad yeah my
aunt [ __ ] hits me with a car
though still chris [ __ ] too
yeah keep the [ __ ] small bills
walking around money tippy needs the
[ __ ]
tipping is the heavy hitters going into
the ira give me the blue face benny's
nut and butt
so this uh oh [ __ ] this uh my computer
just died
um it's okay t-bone has my charger um
so they give out they give out the
[ __ ]
uh gift cards to everybody and then they
call dinner so everybody goes into
dinner
and my mom was like oh [ __ ] my cell
phone or something went back oh
and one of the guests was digging
through her purse
opening up the [ __ ] this is how they
just were they
gift cards they were some for me they
were because like we
you know my siblings didn't go that was
always a good feeling too when you got
money when you were a kid
right to your [ __ ] handler right to
mom right to mom well we weren't even
honey put this in the purse for me will
you
i'll get it on the ride home we weren't
even there i was like hey give this to
the kids you know
whatever because um where were you
different people different aspects of
the family
keeping things vague trump's trying to
[ __ ] pin me down will ya
it was me i was going but my mom came
out and the person was opening up the
box
to steal the gift card out to then close
the box put the box back in the purse
so you don't even know it's gone until
you get home i'm like was it even in
there on a check
real shyster move needless to say those
people were not invited back to the
patty
ouch from then on ouch i do used to say
a parker said around christmas
really gets you in tune with the
holidays it's nice
sure it gives you that warm fuzzy
feeling
you know what i'm saying uh no i was
never big into narcotics foley big booze
guys well we all have our own family
traditions
big thing my uncle shout out to my uncle
john and my uncle
mike on christmas day we all go to my
aunt's house and she's got this old
[ __ ] she just sold it though she just
she had this old [ __ ]
stone house out in east falls which is
like real [ __ ] old-school money it
was like you know
oh there's like the house from the 1800s
real [ __ ] nice
looks like it would be on a [ __ ]
norman rockwell painting inside's all
[ __ ] dumb she cooked his huge dinner
and my uncle john makes [ __ ]
manhattans and that's when we all drink
manhattans that night
and the [ __ ] martini glass and they
call him loudmouth soup
my uncle have about six of those and
start telling you how he really feels
about something
and we love it dude every time we show
up we're like [ __ ] hit me with the
manny's you know what i mean we [ __ ]
go
oh it's great and like you get to the
point where he's ordering like these
like [ __ ] 40
things of cherries offline that's like
the best eye brandy cherry's
delicious nothing's better than rolling
in there and a fresh sweater
[ __ ] getting handed a [ __ ]
manhattan the fire's going the [ __ ]
ham's cooking the steaks cooking
i never felt comfortable in anything i
wore on christmas because that's exactly
what you said and as a fat kid
it nothing else nothing ever i always
hated my [ __ ] brother my brother
was a [ __ ] good-looking like athletic
build he could take
a suit off the rack and it fit you know
what i mean me i'm like my [ __ ] pants
are over my shoes and
[ __ ] stepping on the heels legs are
running together there's no room in the
crotch
yeah it's bad my [ __ ] undershirt's
showing it's [ __ ]
i look like a [ __ ] asian like the
last 20 minutes of a wedding
yeah um all right let's [ __ ] start
cooking through some of these hit me
um this is from this is f we kind of
touched on it a little bit this is from
kristen kennedy in the facebook group
one of my husband's uncles dresses up as
santa at the family christmas party
he has each kid son on his lap and they
get a gift and then he spends the rest
of the night trying to get his family's
wives or girlfriends on his lap
telling uncle danny to back the [ __ ] off
is now an annual tradition
jesus yikes he can't expose i don't
stuff like that
i don't trust anybody in a [ __ ] santa
suit i do santa claus
yeah i don't trust you i do it great i
get a pill head like you in a santa suit
there's no barrier
just talking about how you're rooting
through your family's medicine cabinet
what's the study of
robbing a liquor store when you already
got the disguise on you know what i mean
it was a fat guy with a beard on this
night
i always do it right uh yeah i know i'm
just saying i i never got we never had
the older pervy guy at the party sucks
my so we do
uh never be that guy we do uh
look at heroin what do you want from
santa yeah meanwhile his wife looks like
a pit boss from caesars
you've been using that punchline for a
decade
[ __ ] turtleneck short haircut wearing
a blazer
you know why stuff changing
[Laughter]
um mine so i think i might have said my
family's so big
that we can't have the the the sullivan
family christmas party at a house
anymore it's just
there's hundreds of people not near a
school um no
so we have it at this hall in in philly
and man uh it's great it's a [ __ ]
polish hall we have it we [ __ ] cater
it
they then we pay a santa to come it's
dj'd we bring a sandwich well that's
weird
what paying this a family member should
do it as long as he ain't a grabber
hiring a guy you know that's when it
gets one of my family's over 300 pounds
so they pay this old [ __ ] out of my
pillow they pay this they pay this guy
to calm dude and i'm not it's like
out of a movie he pulls up in a [ __ ]
crunched up
ford ranger he's dude he's [ __ ] three
sheets to the wind and we're like oh
sand is here dude he stumbles out of the
car they said something to him last year
because it was dude he pulls up out
front parker
same dude yeah we've been getting him
for like a decade he puts like the car
half up on the curb half off because
it's in port richmond and like the tide
signing tiny little side street
he pulls up on the curb out front he
goes where am i going we like move
we move them in we sit him down on the
[ __ ] in a chair and the kids come up
and we say hey this gift's for toby this
gives for stevie and he hands it out
to the little kids and then he [ __ ]
we hand him like [ __ ] four bills he
hops in the car and [ __ ] crunches his
way down
he stinks like roasted oh dude he's
[ __ ]
he should not be driving this just reeks
of aju and jin
[ __ ] nick nolte showing up to a road
[Laughter]
jesus yeah um
all right let's see what else do we got
give me this is
all right i'm getting there buddy this
is from zack buckman uh on the facebook
uh he this is just a statement which is
pure trash got condoms as a stocking
stuffer from my mom when i was like 12
years old
12. i think she was trying to give me a
signal
no [ __ ] she was looking for the high
heat she probably got stuck in the
dishwasher later that night meet me over
the media under the mistletoe big boy
it's a deep cut if you're into that kind
of pornography
stuck porn ladies and gentlemen i've
never never seen a stepmom get her hand
caught
listen this is what happens she takes
her ring off to do the dishes
it falls down the sink she puts her hand
down there and then
i guess she doesn't realize that you
close the hand to pull it out she's got
her hand open so she can't get it out
she's jerking
the step brother come the stepson comes
he starts poking hey what are you doing
she goes i don't try to he goes maybe
i'll try to pull you out
i've never seen it this is why i've read
the cliffs notes uh
you get real specific over there you man
that i mean that's like what porn do you
watch that's a trope in porn now that's
like that happen that's like you see
memes like that like oh my stepsister
got caught in the window what's a trope
this is your comedic genius ladies i'm
being serious a trope is like a thing
that's used that's an old trope like an
old device
oh okay it's pronounced troop i believe
no it's trope is it toby just doesn't
even look over just
it's not i'm not even on mic well we
could split hairs all day here if we
want
um yeah my body i remember my buddy like
tina 14 15 16 maybe he got like a carton
of new ports
and this is from like a learned family
like his dad was like a financial
advisor just to go back i think that mom
was probably worried about him you know
one you know was looking for safe sex
you never know start you know start
figuring out yeah
i think that the appropriate thing would
to have a conversation and say hey i
don't think you're ready for this
yeah you don't just [ __ ] throw
batteries don't throw a thing of [ __ ]
you know trojans in there and hope for
the best
rib for her pleasure this is pretty
funny this is from scott
don't be lea i [ __ ] your name up last
time and you got pissed at me i don't
care thank you scotty uh shout out to
scotty
my mom had these wood blocks that
spelled out noel i always used to switch
them to spell leon which is a [ __ ]
home run of a joke dude that's a [ __ ]
home run that's so funny to me
i i dude i read that one and and i laugh
leon just something like dude that's so
funny to me
ah that's [ __ ] gold which then the
coolest thing you're got a [ __ ]
awesome family that became one of our
traditions and now
i own the blocks and that's just what we
do because i also used to put mr t in
the manger
[Laughter]
oh mister i think i got a mr t one year
the
best mr t and the smurfs big but h music
yeah i was phased that was too young i
was gonna say crying i i cried when i
got uh
i don't know why my mom got me a a towel
set of the smurfs
like a washcloth a towel and like a bat
kid likes to bath huh jesus christ
tubby time with kippy on the top layer
for patreon when i opened it up i
started crying
because i love the smurf so much man
you are twisted i've never seen anybody
[ __ ] cry over a rag before
oh my god it's terry cloth
oh i love terry um leon
that's awesome this is from lex adams
growing up my dad was too cheap to buy a
tall christmas tree so he would buy a
medium christmas tree and
oh my god he would put it on top of a
spare tire in the living room wow and
then covered it with a tree skirt
wow wow wow
my dad my dad always used to go too big
we did have a big
a big a tall ceiling in our living room
because it was like a sun like a step
down in the living room so it was you
know it was like an extra foot higher or
whatever
the living room my dad's house and would
buy like a [ __ ] 12 foot tree
and then cut the top off so it was like
flat on the top yeah it's weird looks
like he joined the military he was like
buddy [ __ ]
once when you ship out hey sailor
dude and tinsel too that's a i mean
there's we got a lot of things like tins
obviously tinsel
trash fake trees trash fake trees trash
i want to know about you which we used
to do
and there's two ways you can do it this
is a kippy um
going to look at lights did you do it
buddy because there's two ways you can
go look at lights you can drive around
neighborhoods the rich neighborhoods
looking at lights or
a lot of parks do it where you drive so
we used to go to like tyler park or
court creek
park or whatever and drive through the
light show which always felt
disingenuous and trashy to me
because it wasn't special it was just a
parade of cars i'm going well like
workers put this people got paid to put
these up yeah well no we had a couple of
hot blocks
yeah the rich the the rich people thing
that was
all the time like that just went looked
at their houses
sure i remember just riding around just
looking at like new homes and stuff like
that we used to do it in high school
me and my friends would get all smoked
up and we just that's different during
the day at school we drive around and
look at that's weight i'm talking about
with your parent you're driving to look
at other you're driving with your
parents looking houses you can't afford
let's go kick the tires see if we can
get an open house
maybe we could um but no all through the
christmas season we would you know
if it was a you know off night we'd
drive around look at people's houses
but there was a there was like a couple
of blocks that were like
this is the christmas and they knew and
they did it and they knew there'd be
like somebody out there collecting money
for charity or some [ __ ] like that too
shabby yeah
[ __ ] blow right by him
[Laughter]
i live down the block now
is he a canadian
yeah yeah all the time yeah
i would if i was going home for
christmas i would that would definitely
be
you know before i went into the house
one night i would take a couple laps on
a neighborhood check to join out
another big thing too people do it nice
people doing my mom which they
one boy sent us uh something on twitter
he said he just got the new house or
he's oh yeah yeah new money looks
[ __ ] great yeah
got to go all out um yeah for sure but
there is a level of trashy
that you can do it if you're sure you
can over the top is funny you're like oh
i get that you're going over the top
especially now which is fine but in the
80s it was
there was the white candles were in the
window there was a couple of [ __ ]
classy
like an actual big wreath with a red big
red bow
never the plastic santa claus or the
colored lights or any of that [ __ ]
remember dude remember when the icicle
lights dropped oh dude
they dropped in the 90s i remember being
like what like that was like
[ __ ] nasty but they were too trashy
that and they were the projector that
projects on the along or the side of the
house or whatever get out of here
also if you have music to your if you're
like if your lights do
you know bounce around the music you
[ __ ] trash a big thing that we used
to do in my [ __ ] parent in my mom's
neighborhood
that they stopped for like 15 years then
got back to it
was the bag the candles that line the
streets
nothing is better cleveland's driving
down it's about
6 p.m and it's just the whole the
[ __ ] way down the street you got to
get the whole hood today
oh it's great it's great i [ __ ] love
it my brother's neighborhood does that
[ __ ]
tight real tight clean living right
there not too shabby
let me ask this did anybody ever have um
the uh
the santa claus or the snowman usually
about two three foot high
you get him at a home depot or uh cbs
you know you touch him and he does you
know hey
inside or outside inside we had a
smaller one and it was like a foot and a
half he would sit and just like kind of
do this like that but
those things creep me this way he would
do like move his hips a little too yeah
i don't like that
what would you say i think coming to get
me in the middle of the night new we
used to do so the front of my house has
this like
we have a big like bay window in the
front of my house right like above the
full in the foyer
and there's like a level up there that
you can't get you got to get a ladder to
get yeah i know what i've seen it i've
been in the joint we used to put i don't
think they do it anymore now they're
older but they used to put like a whole
[ __ ] uh
setting up there it was like two it was
like a street it was like kind of like
you know it was a street
and there was like a store maybe two
street two like light poles
that were like three or four foot high
two people that used to like wave and do
this it was all fake snow
used to you used to hear the [ __ ]
motors running in the middle of the
night
creeped me out daddy oh no way
he's the [ __ ] shooting with my bb gun
take them out
well you know we were all about the
trains growing up two platforms of
[ __ ] lionel christmas trains
which i don't i i i i i just my stepdad
tried to get a few saturdays before
christmas those boxes smell those
engines i love
love that smell [ __ ] put down the
fake grass
dad's got a couple of pops in them
smoking cigs clean
living americana right there fake snow i
told you we used to use the uh
artificial uh mashed potatoes as the
fake snow on them
also do you ever do spray snow that
stuff stinks
put it on the windows i went out last
night with my wife who
we were like looking for like that's her
chopping bodies
stuff for the [ __ ] studio and looking
at your present and [ __ ]
you're stalking and uh there was a can
of spray she's like oh how about this
i'm like you got a lot to learn toots
because they ain't never going anywhere
in my [ __ ] house
it's like [ __ ] spray paint yes the
[ __ ] they used to mark out a soccer
field
[ __ ] no way
uh this is this is from jose uh
and you know i get this it can be a
prank type thing whatever whatever
is it trash to put the gifts inside a
box inside another box inside another
box inside another box
or they're like that's new boyfriend
[ __ ] or you put something inside like a
playstation box and it's like you know
a dvd that's more hack than it is yeah
that's hacked now
and that's something it can pay off
pretty good sometimes you can be like ah
you got him once in a while that's
something the fiance does when he's
asking her to marry him in front of
her family or something like that that's
what you got to be doing if it's just
like you
two tickets or something it's [ __ ]
lame in a big box
also uh that being said
we've gotten so many questions and stuff
uh about
pollyanna's the you know the white
elephant the secret santa
the whatever whatever we talked about it
the yankee swap yankee swap
[ __ ] animals we just take the present
you want we talked about it briefly
it's trash right maybe a straight up
pollyanna is nice
it's all right yeah you and your cousins
okay i got tiffany i got two
i got john so yeah yeah you you set a
limit 25 bucks everybody always goes
over
and just gets each other one nice thing
a bottle of cologne
nice bottle of wine [ __ ] you know
whatever
sure that's all right even at work too
the pollyanna's okay i get you know i
get works a little different because
it's like they got to create a culture
and they want to sure
whatever it's not you know it's not by
choice but that yankee that
pot thing whatever that's no well i want
steve's and i won't do
we did it for a couple of years and
people got [ __ ]
butt hurt dude like there was like
people were upset yeah you buy something
for yourself
people buy like a cd player then they
end up with like a [ __ ] turkey baster
they're like what the [ __ ] was this all
about you know what i mean
[Laughter]
people get [ __ ] butthurt yeah quick
we never even uh our family's pretty
cool with that stuff like uh i think
maybe they do family presence now but we
don't even really do the pollyanna
i don't know there was so many kids born
at the same time that that's
that was like a good transition from
like all right we're all too old to be
exchanging gifts with
you know 25 people sure sure yeah i mean
cash
who invited this guy jesus krampus over
here
it's [ __ ] getting this guy a bowl of
soup when you and your cousins
put everybody's name in a hat and you
pull out your body you pick your name i
secret santa yeah secret santa pollyanna
we used to call it chinese that's what
you got in your sats
wow really it hit in the 90s the chinese
pollyanna and also i remember
i don't sound kosher the first time we
did it i think was at like my aunt
quinny's house it was that my aunt
queenie or was aunt sue's that adds up
it was somebody's house and if you and
if you pulled the right one you had to
do blackface
so they they i remember being like this
is gonna everything like some of my
uncle's like what the [ __ ] are we doing
i ain't doing it give me a vlog
give me a but you know like but they
were like let it hap and i mean
it like it was an event and i remember
some people trying to unders
there was always like four people that
can't understand the premise or the
rules they're like i get a pro
oh you got to pick any present you know
what number did you get that shit's dumb
it's trashy just buy someone a [ __ ]
gift or don't and move it the [ __ ]
yeah once the kids came along as long as
you [ __ ] broke the kids off and
hooked them up nice i can relax through
the whole party
this is from uh work the hors d'oeuvres
this is from facebook group as well by
the way shout out to the facebook group
shout out you guys have that [ __ ]
love for the pod baby
oh my god the wild west out there his
name
his name is kuvid19
i don't know if that's his government
name that's great he goes at some point
this is [ __ ] bananas at some point
growing up we stopped taking the
decorations off the fake tree
and we wrapped it i wrapped a blanket
around it and dragged it like a dead
body
up the attic ladder i could see it
what yeah it's trash but i can see it
since spending saving time but i thought
you were johnny christmas party i
am i would part of it is like i said i
can't see it from somebody else's point
of view
no i think part of the the part of the
tree is getting the trees of course it
is
of course [ __ ] dragon put a christmas
movie on when you get the tree you bring
it back you put it up you water it
you let it open up then you bring all
this [ __ ] down letting it fall i
remember just wanting to going to buy it
and decorate it my dad's like
you got to let that fall you got to let
it settle
i get that i'm saying as a kid all i
ever want to do is [ __ ] decorate it
yeah and it was like you got to wait 48
hours i'm like [ __ ] this dude
the whole the whole thing is decorated
we always order chinese that's what we
do
always what's what's more what's more
trash though wrapping it up and keeping
the things on or taking it down
the night of like that one lady their
grandpa
that's that's that's that's just
heartbreaking that's the both of them
are kind of
i mean i get it that he's got to go but
it's a little as a little kid
like what the [ __ ] you can't wait one
day
or leave it up and take it down when you
get back well none of this is a real
treat
i think she said it was a fake i could
be wrong maybe it wasn't real i forget
either way grandpas aren't doing that
[ __ ] they're old like korean war vets
and [ __ ] like that
they get [ __ ] done yeah
that's worse though taking the tree down
while you're eating [ __ ] dinner
because you're going to tampa i'm going
to tampa
shout out to tampa i know uh you should
see the hotel we're staying at the don
cesar
very nice google it it's [ __ ] the dan
marino it's about 400 bucks a night
is it nothing on the dan marino come on
dan marino whatever is it pink yeah yeah
yeah yeah
oh that spot yeah those my parents used
to live like 15 minutes from yeah that's
where we're going
going to toby's parents for christmas
can't wait to get my soup
tell him to heat up oh [ __ ] tell him to
heat up some chunks
i'm not bringing you home a bowl of soup
chowder for me
it's not the holidays he's like breaking
in my mom's house do some pills get a
soup
no one year one year after christmas we
went down to a hotel on the beach so
like
it's like like a getaway getaway you
know what i mean like a little
staycation
yeah and i was like 17 and i remember
uh my my folks went out and i was
sitting at home alone like christmas
movies on the [ __ ]
on the [ __ ] hotel tv i was like [ __ ]
this i'm getting drunk and i went
downstairs to the next floor found where
the maids were cleaning found an
open room cleared out their mini bar and
just got christ
freaking bombed he's right down the
beach from the dances he's like a grown
little rascal
home alone four over here yeah toby
mcallister getting into some mischief
chicago so r.i.p to that person's bill
gee yeah what a dirt ball this guy's
[ __ ] trash ruined some guy's marriage
there wasn't any uh like luggage or
anything i think they were turning it
over someone just left yeah then they
blamed the maids they'd probably get
fired yeah
i didn't think about that of course you
did it
well you enjoy that tonight when you're
trying to go to sleep
i don't think it's going to phase them
uh this is [ __ ]
this is from kyle noel noel every year
before me and the wife had kids we would
take a bottle a piece
bourbon for me flavored vodkes for the
wife trash
trash to the four christmases we had
both parents are divorced
then at the end of the night we went to
applebee's for jello shots
cheap beer and half half priced apps
which i can say
is trash good for you but i do not hate
that's [ __ ] something else dude half
price ass
half dude all night because you're i
know that feeling because i would do it
we would go to the [ __ ] rich borough
pub after
christmas night so like my mom would go
to my step-dad's place my brother and
sister and i would meet up
i'd go to my aunts and we'd do dinner
and i would drive back to where to my
mom's area and meet him a couple of my
[ __ ] buddies would meet up and just
have [ __ ]
that's not stress but like the i'm done
like
all of my responsibilities are done i
went because my family got like 19
people i got to see i got 20 presents i
got to buy for everybody so it's like
this is now me time i get to relax with
a couple of [ __ ] buddies have a
couple of pints
maybe a couple of pub wings good night
i gotta get you a pub wing by the way
the rich borough pub they do
blue cheese and hot sauce together and
give it to you like that
it'll blow your way what do you mean
it's already tossed in the blue yeah
they toss it in everything
and it comes out like glowing orange not
like hot sauce like
it looks like neon r it's so [ __ ]
good yeah
yeah we'll try them on the patreon oh
there we go
um did you i guess no you're like very
traditional you never went anywhere on
christmas or anything
like you you know now what do you mean
we would go we would do criminal house i
can ask you we do christmas
you never like leave like okay i'm gonna
go do this with my friends or go to my
friend's house and do whatever like
i also like popping around my buddy's
house i would no
no i would get to um i would get to go
over to my high school girlfriend's
parents i'm not saying as a kid i'm
saying as a young adult yeah as a young
adult
yes so your high school girlfriend's
parents yeah when i was in high school
and college i'd be able to dip out a
couple hours and go there and you know
get do presents with them okay i was
allowed to go to the bars
you're a [ __ ] dork dude yeah
meanwhile the [ __ ] kids are running
i always wanted to go home and hang out
with my parents anyway like get home
around eight or nine on christmas day
pop the feet up watch a movie okay
um i always do get into the christmas
cookies that we took
we always took cookies with you we have
uh
the [ __ ] was that i don't know
something's going on outside it's not
like a gunshot
um as we got older we would always go i
go over my buddy pat's house
for a couple of pops after now like i do
with my wife we go to my
my buddy pat's house see them because
they're like my [ __ ] second parent so
yeah you know
everything then we go we walked down to
my buddy flip's house shout out to flip
we drink and smoke in his place you know
a couple of good bottles of whiskey
everybody's hanging and it's like this
cool tradition that i finally have of
myself
like of my own wow i mean like we go i
go over to pat's house to see his
parents i got you the group grows we go
down to chris's the more people come
we see it's the only time in the year i
see his parents
everybody brings a good whiskey with
this that good bottle of wine
everybody's outside smoking burning
and he ended up at some dirt ball bar at
two in the morning shout out to steam
looking for it looking for a 20 bag i
don't know how it works yeah
uh we stopped go now that my wife comes
the past two years we stopped going to
the bar afterwards they're just [ __ ]
hopping in ubs
that's nice but yeah it's [ __ ] a okay
can't do it this year though
can't do it this year but it makes you
take stock and being grateful for next
year
yeah that's what it's all about um this
one comes from will
uh then we can we go we gotta wrap it up
here um
from the patreon have you ever been
kicked out of an office christmas party
now maybe not kicked out but have you
ever done anything
freaky at christmas have you ever done
something embarrassing or freaky
at a company christmas party my anxiety
is so bad that every time i was in one
of those situations
if i drank too much i'd wake up the next
day like i never
wanted to go to the to the brunch after
a wedding
because i what did i do what did i say
you know what i mean
although there's [ __ ] the waffle
stations
nothing better than that yeah a buffet
breakfast at a hotel
oh man no never been thrown out but
definitely worried about what i said or
did the next day
i uh i was only 22 or i was working at a
law firm in philly
and we like went out it was like a bar
crawl with the whole office it was all
young dirt balls bad news
and it was like 20 of us we're gonna go
to finn mccool's first for an hour we
got a special there then we're gonna pop
over to the
[ __ ] tavern on broad for an hour let
me tell you something there's somebody
in the service industry i hate it
you [ __ ] people you know i'm sorry
you don't want my money i'm coming in
there
on youtube you're not dropping [ __ ] you
guys aren't tipping and you're using
your company card at the end
and whatever who do you think has a
company card what do you mean there was
always one card
put a tab for the for the no it wasn't a
party we were coming into the bar like
to the bar and they were all
paying everybody well then i apologize
to you and your friends yeah you just
don't like me
but the the kind of [ __ ] you come in
you know
the companies that do that where there's
one card where somebody has a company
yeah company credit card
they said put it all on this here open
the tab they order they don't tip their
[ __ ] dicks and at the end of the
at the end of the uh thing some
jerk off who spent too much of the
company's money tries to make up for
that by shortchanging the [ __ ]
service
so [ __ ] you and your softball team what
do you think about that
this guy's a this guy's a bowl of laughs
today um
but we went out so we get all [ __ ]
bombed up sure
kippy starts talking to some lady and
[ __ ] i don't know what department she
was but it wasn't the attractive one
yeah right that was gold right buddy
that's what pays the bills around here
toby so if you don't like it
i'll give you your walking papers
you're the head of the busted team
aren't you
she tried to copy your ass on the copy
or bro
she's got a couple of socos and limes in
her we were doing some shooters
outside smoking with her yeah that was
always
that was always the way you were in the
song of smoke stevie you know you can
finally get some alone time start
talking make a move huh
disgusting but we like
made out like [ __ ] idiots and luckily
did people see it
a handful yeah i don't know if they saw
it or if it was like
people knew what was up unless you were
unless you're both
extremely attractive which we were not
myself included i was vice president of
the ugly
i'm sure you look like two octopus
fighting over a [ __ ]
goldfish yeah unless you're super super
both people are super super hot that's
really frowny but like she was dating
i didn't know all right so i was also
talking so one of the
boss's sons worked for the company as
well who i was tight with
i didn't know they were like secretly
not secretly dating but like
they had a hiss or something there was
something there which i didn't know yeah
so i'm probably starting last year at
the christmas party
brook's got an mo so i'm like talking to
him like i think i got a shot with her
and he's just like
like i didn't realize i was like i was
doing it right in front of him and i
didn't realize i was being a [ __ ]
[ __ ] because i don't know
how mum's the [ __ ] word her fault
right depending you know
so meanwhile this guy was way hotter
than i am had way more way more cash
dad's name was on the building yeah so
i don't realize so then like we were
gonna go home together
but i lost my credit card or so i had to
like go back or
something i went back to the ball kids
as smooth as they come man
talk about clunky trying to save the
deal it's like
i asked how to get smokes real quick
before we get back to your place you got
roommates
no trash like oh i got to run into the
ball i had to go back into something and
then okay you couldn't it's just like
you leave your car and all over town
i'll tell you that
yeah i remember he's [ __ ] going to
pick it up in madrid yeah
2015 the [ __ ] 2019 up here you
[ __ ]
this guy johnny leaves a car yeah you're
like cinderella [ __ ] the magic
dd bank card well when you're closing
the deal you can't wait to close out a
tab
buddy i'll come back tomorrow ain't
nothing audit anyway see you monday when
i picked the car up
yeah i'm not getting rejected in person
um
and thank god so like it was super
awkward the next day like it was like
or not the next day i think it was we
went in monday right so it was like you
had the weekend but then you're like
still in your head i was just weird
that's not weird
that type thing we went in it was
awkward and then luckily i was [ __ ]
skedaddled not too long after but
thank god dude anytime he makes [ __ ]
christmas parties and co-workers or
somebody's saying something not
everybody's sense of humor lines up it's
not good and people start making out
doing this snorting you think
everybody's cool with coke they're not
all right let's wrap i think everyone's
down for a hooker you find out the hard
way
i think everybody's down for a gang bang
meanwhile
uh guys thank you so much for writing in
we appreciate all the [ __ ]
uh all the participation all the support
these are our favorite [ __ ] episodes
absolutely
happy uh holidays uh merry christmas
happy holidays merry christmas happy
hanukkah
happy new year happy everything to
everybody we really appreciate all the
[ __ ] support
oh yeah we can't stress it enough this
year has been you know i don't want to
sound [ __ ] cheesy but we owe a lot to
all you guys and we appreciate all the
[ __ ] support
uh this year has been a [ __ ]
whirlwind for us and you know thank you
so much for supporting us and being on
our [ __ ] side and helping us
you know keep this thing growing we
really [ __ ] appreciate it big things
coming to 2021 gang
big things yeah
like sugar free russell stovers
christmas candy
gang we'll see you next week we love you
peace peace